so there's been new footage for love and
thunder in the form of a tv spot and a
new image let's break it down the first
new shot is a four holding zeus's
thunderbolt and it looks like he is
harnessing the energy from it as he
summons this energy field around him
possibly learning new powers and
abilities from zeus's thunderbolt which
it looks like he'll be using this
thunderbolt actually quite a bit because
in the next shot we have him in a fight
against gold or gold butcher now in an
interview christian bale said he gives
four a run for his money so i feel like
this fight is going to be really intense
and hopefully brutal now one thing that
i actually did find surprising is that
zeus's thunderbolt is like an actual
prop an actual thunderbolt as opposed to
like an actual like energy bolt that is
summoned and just held in the hand next
up we have new footage and a dialogue
sequence and the delivery here is really
really good so i'm just gonna play the
clip for you
now one thing to note is it does look
like thor is going to be extremely
powerful in this movie so i know a lot
of people are going to be happy about
that and then we also have a quick new
shot of valkyrie under pegasus which it
looks like she throws a spear into the
distance and then to end off the new
stuff we have this image here and it's
just an image of all mighty thor and
valkyrie nothing really much to break
down on this image here but it looks
like it would take place just before the
scene where thor is captured by zeus
anyway that's pretty much everything for
this breakdown so if you did enjoy
please like and subscribe and turn
notifications on to show your support
thanks for watching